tour de babel en avignon 25 comédiens
appartenant à 16 nationalités
différentes pour une seule et même pièce
une pièce indienne ou plutôt un conte
mahabharata mise en scène par peter
brook adaptée par jean claude carrière
les spectateurs devront apporter leur
sandwich la pièce dure 9 heures france
roche une carrière de pierre du théâtre
une légende indienne changé en pièces
françaises de 9 heures les comédiens de
toutes les couleurs qui jouent des
roises et des dieux armés d'arcs et de
flèches
c'est le mahabharata de peter brook et
jean claude carrière entamée à l'union
après ça le voyage en inde du kerala où
va la barre c'est une super bande
dessinée est mort c'est très très longue
histoire donc je craque à un bande
dessinée il ya 300 400 petits volumes
qui seconde et pour les indiens c'est un
peu comme la bible nacre était comme
shakespeare de de l'autre m
toute la troupe des bouffes du nord a
amenés ici c'est entre ses habitudes et
ses costumes problèmes de transport
d'abord on est à 12 km d'avignon de
température aussi car il fait 40 degrés
à l'ombre
parce que il ya des problèmes pratiques
c'est à dire que dans la journée il ya
la poussière dès le soleil la nuit
illimitée dès la rosée
il ya tout et il faut protéger ces
tissus qui sont quand même très très
très délicat
cette carrière d'où l'on a extrait jadis
500 tonnes de pierres peter brook en
fait les décors de la saga des corps va
aider panda va tu dois apprendre encore
cette légende deux frères ennemis qui se
déchirent se perdent et se retrouve elle
les spécialistes mahabharata un appel à
la conscience de toutes les générations
c'est une grande histoire de l'humanité
avec le copain de cette manière d'abord
c'est plutôt un balayage des images
d'epinal de fausses idées de fantasmes
et je crois que nous revenons en donnant
plus réaliste en essayant olympiques et
aux traditions indiennes et en même
temps à essayer de trouver une manière à
refléter ce qui pour nous était
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est plutôt
comme un comment parfum connaissait de
la flatter que des choses que des
détails congrès à ta vie qui va
s'arrêter la douche à sanaa bush à sanaa
ki moon est la bac